just like everything else the reading
habits of Americans have been influenced
by technology a study by the Pew
Research Center found that 23 percent of
Americans listen to at least one
audiobook over the last year and 30
percent read an e-book which may be an
all-time high but the old-fashioned
paper volume is still the first choice
for most Americans and some are doing
everything that they can despite online
competition to keep the experience of
buying and reading books fresh like a
bookstore we visited in downtown
Portland Oregon
look at all these people on a Monday on
a Monday I know for more than 50 years
Pal's books has been the go-to spot for
Book Lovers from Portland and Beyond
Saint Austin from the classics
two more modern tones all the great
we're in a good section right here their
shelves are jam-packed with nearly a
million volumes people keep writing
books that's how we keep it fresh
there's an unending Supply it's how
president and owner Emily Powell says
she's managed to stay competitive in a
market where the Giants have swallowed
up so many other Independents and chains
I mean to say you're passionate about
this place yeah it's an understatement
that's right because this is a family
affair that's right my father started
the business in Chicago but then my
grandfather opened the first Powells in
Portland and so when I walk in here and
I see the old tile and the main entrance
or I just smell the air it smells like
my grandfather to me yeah to me this is
home it's that feeling pal tries to
replicate for her customers in the 70
000 square feet of retail space I always
think a big part of our business is
making just enough money for all the
people who read our books and don't buy
them how many authors have I heard say
to me over the years I sat for hours for
days on the floor reading and
researching for my next book thank you
for not kicking me out that's a big part
of what we do make your customer feel at
home in a place in a world that often
doesn't have a home for them it's hard
to talk about Portland without
mentioning the city's struggles during
the pandemic including a rise in
homelessness
[Applause]
and widespread protests during the
social justice movement
sparked by George Floyd's murder
many downtown businesses closed
including Pals which laid off about 500
staffers how tough was that it was
excruciating but I also knew that What
mattered most was that we'd come back
that we you know wait this out that we
keep everyone safe that we make sure no
one got sick just because they were
coming to work and and that we come out
the other side those who were rehired
started from square one with some long
time workers losing seniority and weeks
of time off why was there a need to have
former employees reapply for work here
well we have a very clear bargain
contract with our Union we're required
to follow it and so for us it wasn't
about making anyone do anything it was
just following the contract that we had
negotiated Powell stayed afloat by
shifting its focus to online sales but
that being said Do You See
business as usual in a pre-pandemic form
in the future never I don't think so I
think we're going to keep finding this
messy middle for a long time I think
this big thing happened to all of us and
we've only just begun to really kind of
feel it and experience it and and know I
mean obviously we've been experiencing
it for two years but I mean let it
settle into our systems and come out
into something else that makes sense on
the other side this is the rare book
room still there are some experiences
that are distinctly Pals what's in here
we have some books that are forty
dollars we have a set of Lewis and Clark
journals that are 350 000. wait wait
where is that well it's not that one's
not out for customers to test history of
the Expedition 25 Grand you got that's
right I think at the end of the day
we're all trying to translate this
really magical in-person experience to
folks who can't be here so how do we get
what happens here in this very special
place to readers in other places how do
you I don't know you'd have to talk to
that person
Powell's belongs to you that person is
social media marketing coordinator Sarah
Reed that's sort of the magic of these
books on their displays is that you find
the one that speaks to you and it speaks
to you from a Bookseller someone has
made that decision we watched as she
created content for tick tock so the
first thing I do I'll try and get a
whole panning shot okay hold this way
okay because we want to give everyone on
Tick Tock the opportunity
to pick their favorite book off of this
display what is book talk it's where
people go in that space to talk about
books and so book talk is the hashtag
but it's also the name of the community
and it is people sharing their Halls
from bookstores so like here's the pile
of books I got today it's bookstores
sharing the interesting content that
exists inside them that maybe I've never
been to this bookstore but I'm obsessed
with them because their personality
Shines on book talk it's authors we are
starting a samurai turn pretty book club
there's authors who use it for
self-promotion who are sort of book talk
royalty book talk is put Jude and carton
back on the best I was and it is
changing our industry I knew I wanted to
do this display long before I had a
catchy name for it Bookseller Charlotte
Starling the display of sad girl summer
found inspiration from social media for
this popular display I didn't know how
to articulate it it's sad woman weird
woman especially in their like 20s and
30s sometimes you're working jobs you
don't like or everything about your life
is changing were you having a sad girl
sorry yes it's a sad girl summer it's
one of those things where it's painful
sometimes to read them but it's so
validating as well it speaks to the
power of Storytelling something Emily
Powell knows will continue to bring
customers through the door I think
they're still really a hunger for
reading for the print book for something
you hold in your hand and you take with
you and people like the smell of our
store you know that very physical
experience of transportation that you
get when you open a book and you let
yourself go into it and I think that our
store connects you to all that's
possible in the world but you can't get
that through an online experience so in
that sense
hope we're here for a really long time
because we're not new and we're not old
it's something really Universal that we
managed to do
and I had not been in a bookstore in
years I mean the covid pandemic
experience was you buy it online you get
an audio book but there were tons of
people in that store and to see them and
with the way they engage with one
another I learned something I had not
heard of book talk could you yeah yeah
of course you had you didn't though I
didn't no bookstores are the they really
were they are they always have been the
best thing they still are you can find a
good one I I did like when she talked
about the messy middle everybody is
still trying to find like post covet and
post everything else the past few years
like that resets yeah and also holding a
physical book I don't know about your
kids but I Know Jack he does like having
I do physical book and I love that he
does because that means they're sort of
safe in that space if the younger ones
do